[Aplausos]
cómo
también existe no debería compartir es
un poquito algunas cosas que no me
conoceríamos armando machuca tengo 42
años y soy montón de cosas soy actor es
un improvisador soy director soy docente
soy soy fricson hijo soy hermano soy
tiro
puyol es entonces que la verdad me falta
a veces vida parece todo lo que quiero
hacer
pero si yo tengo que cerrar hay algún
concepto ya donde dice estas ganas
piensa hacer tantas cosas y quizás lo
que come concluyó
en actor es que desde niño me encantaron
las historias desde niño me han
fascinado las historias yo este vídeo
15 minutos de por acá en el rímac en la
vida de trápaga 73 el próximo día de
este lustro un niño de los 80s entonces
de niño no va a trabajar un montón yo
soy la hermana mayor esposa pasado
bastante tiempo solo y me pegaba con las
historias de la televisión y cuando
podía escapar al cine
yo de niño tenía muchos seres queridos
yo quería tener mi auto fantástico con
nike ya no quería saber hacer mis cosas
como activer ya quería poder de echar
como batán y como rama
y toda esta tribu eran pueblos
creo que eso hizo que siempre me
fascinar a las historias fui creciendo
estudie comunicaciones
me hice actor y un día llegó a mí una
palabra maravillosa que es la
improvisación teatral que es base que es
dentro de todo lópez es contador de gas
quizás el concepto que te lo que me
define yo soy un improvisador que qué
cosa es un improvisador qué tal un
improvisador es un actor que se entrega
para contar y crear historias de manera
inmediata frente a un público escucha y
ideas que le da a la gente y sobre eso
con mi cuerpo mi cabeza y lo que
alrededor creó una historia y bueno así
este tren de la universidad entra un
grupo que se llama pataclaun y estuve
varios años ahí y me consciente de la
improvisación y fueron años maravillosos
maravillosos años que seguramente muchos
de ustedes seguramente ustedes ignacio
porque ni siquiera había facebook no
había con las motos había internet para
contarte conectarte a necesitar de tener
que apretar un poder es una marca
y después de siete horas presente
conectadas era otro universo de instalar
no tenían celulares el escándalo
después de estar siempre para televisión
teatro y últimos dos últimos años y sin
esto detrás de la televisión creando
dirigiendo etcétera etcétera hecho radio
pero el paso se hace un par de años algo
algo muy interesante
me di cuenta que tanto me gustaban las
historias de niño que yo quería hacer de
mi historia una historia espectacular
quería hacer una trilogía de película
de cosas
y eso es todo lo que les dije a pensar
porque de pronto después de todo este
historia ha querido construir
un poco solo
no ha cambiado
para que el otro
una jarana era una tortura y de pronto
me di cuenta que algo estaba mal que no
estaba completamente contento
esto se decide tener en la vida es como
en google
el auto fantástico
de instalar las piezas las tuercas
manejas ya de siete más a dónde quieres
ver cuando me di cuenta que quizás mi
carrito de la vida no estaba avanzando
también entonces dije a ver el momento
de detenerme por respirar y ver qué
cosas no está funcionando y para eso
dije voy a retroceder de pasado
vamos a ver qué hay qué pasa qué
herramientas uso para pensar qué
herramientas podía utilizar para hacer
esta revisión de vida entonces regresé a
unos momentos más felices que tienen mi
vida
y hacer aprendí la improvisación la
improvisación tiene algún montón de
conceptos pero voy a contarles unos 4
básicos básicamente lo que antes lo que
han hecho es generar miami preguntas y
utilizando esos conceptos que utilizó
para actuar para improvisar para
realizar mi vida y genera los puntos de
cuestionamientos que de pronto les
dejamos los cuestionamientos y quizás
les sirva un poquito la provincia por
ejemplo que para poder crear uno tiene
que saber escuchar entonces pese a
escuchar los de los amigos a los cuales
realmente no me llaman las cuentas
reportaron el problema
escuchar
aislado
tú sabes escuchar qué cosa es escuchar
cuántas veces al día o cuántas veces en
el año
pues tú no sabes que tienes en tu mundo
no universo
les han dicho alguna vez que no saben
escuchar tu pareja
a veces uno como fue interiorizando eso
me di cuenta que habían había algo que
estaba mal escucha que yo creía que
estaba que escuchaba cuando alguien
alguien que me quería necesidad lo
positivo de cómo mejorar las cosas que
estaba haciendo y me di cuenta ese
revisar y escuchar no es lo mismo que
entender
ustedes saudita están contigo que está
prestando atención y me entienden
hablamos el disminuyó donald vamos en el
mismo lenguaje algunos de pronto estarán
escuchando y el que no solamente estarán
encendidos sobre todo los que hacen así
en su cabeza está pensando si dejaron
prendida la cocina cómo se va a nerea
acá después en una punta también salen
cosas uno cree que
escuchar y por qué
quiero que voltee y escojan una pareja
rápidamente la que está a la derecha a
la izquierda adelante o atrás así lo
conozcas y si no lo conoces mejor
solamente quiero que lo mires a los ojos
sin hablar 5 segundos sin hablar voy a
contar hasta 3 sólo se miran a los ojos
no apunten la cara
mírense de verdad hagan el esfuerzo
no tiene que ver con tener algo
por vida con experiencia
estoy terminando los ojos vistos 1 2 3
pero
ya tienen
escuchar es poder tomarte el tiempo de
involucrarte realmente con la persona
que está delante
y en ese momento en ese instante como
este pequeño ejercicio esa persona que
está delante tuyo es lo más importante
del universo es tan importante que todo
lo que esa persona me vaya a decir o
comunicar me va a aceptar
escuchar es la voluntad de cambiar
escuchar es la voluntad de notificarle
de valorar tanto lo que el otro el mundo
lo que me rodea la información que te
llega que si los equipos yo escucho
porque sé que ha de escuchar me voy a
transformar
me di cuenta que yo no estaba escuchando
ya me había acostumbrado a hacer sobre
todo cuando uno tiene cierto nivel de
logros en su vida unos acostumbres a las
cosas de una sola manera y deja de
escuchar porque tienen
aplican muchísimas yo les pregunto
ustedes ustedes escuchan me entiende
así yo la escuché pero
[Música]
luego con un improvisador empieza a
crear una historia
ya lo de eso creo de eso viene este
escucharlo bien el aceptar le pregunto
una cosa ustedes aceptan
que se aceptaba a otras personas que
dicen sí constantemente o son personas
que dicen no no no no no
4 s al día tú dices no podemos aceptar
cosas
pero quizás más tarde esa persona decís
una persona de los primeros de
cuestionamientos no que tres personales
pues bien vamos vamos a acertar causa ya
hay títulos vidas
era todo
pero es importante para tu postura es
importante
[Aplausos]
para que me complico si igual igual en
el fondo lo está pensando total mis
ideas no son tan valoradas y de
veracidad de los más importantes días
para que decir
para que aceptar que miedo donde estamos
no hay que evolucionar me di cuenta que
no aceptaba ni acepta nos lleva a una
tercera palabra
el complementario ahora sí vamos para
adelante
vamos vamos
por acá por acá
si escucho en aceptar se aceptó lo
siguiente paso es comentar
es tomar decisiones para avanzar tú
tomas decisiones o solo acercas y
después que decía nosotros porque me da
miedo decidir me la quedo avanzar y la
última palabra importantísima es el
riesgo
para algunos el riesgo es salir
soy una persona arriesgada soy bueno
mucho más alto
pero los riesgos realmente tienen que
ver con la capacidad que nosotros
tenemos de salir de nuestras zonas
cómodas yo te pregunto tú eres una
persona arriesgada y me preguntaba a mí
mismo yo soy una persona ordenada de
pronto por eso nos tengan contento estoy
tomando riesgos para el bonos de pronto
ser arriesgado es ponerse pantalón rojo
por no ser transado pantalón negro
yo quiero poner pata los rojos
y con tu novia encima porque meter toda
tu vida
pero ya estoy grande rojo estas chicas
no se pueden dar
y nunca tomó riesgos y para otros
riesgos esa baja persona y pedir perdón
cuando sabes que tienes que pedir
diego más grande todavía es saber
perdonar cuando sabes que si no tienes
esa carga
vivir podrido
tú eres una persona que asume riesgos
entonces hace dos años me pasó eso
utilicé esas herramientas para pensar
escucho realmente lo que te pasa lo que
te rodea acepto realmente
porque es lo que es estoy acertando y
estoy complementando estoy fumando ideas
para salir adelante y pongo riesgos y me
di cuenta que no
que no derecho bastantes cosas de su
vida pero no está pero me había olvidado
de que este auto que les hablaba al
principio en la vida se va a desafinar
porque en la vida más al hachís te
peleás te enamoras trigo odian te odias
tuvieras de trabajo así que es un
trabajo constante nuestra carretera
asfaltada es una trocha
secartys al banco
como este lado de tu vida
la vuelta de tuerca y hacer eso
y voy a darle una vuelta de tuerca arco
las piezas para que no sea necesario ok
voy a escuchar que esta paz
está pasando
no sé hasta qué voy a hacer mucho que
aprender cómo aprender qué están
haciendo los jóvenes
porque estaba haciendo
ah
escuchen
por qué
sólo dinero porque tengo más de 20 años
enseñando
ya lo enseñan un rato
ya que hace muchos años
he estado casi de sistema
si no escuchar lo que más a la familia
me encanta
al margen de esto
por qué
lo que puede ser un portal es un portal
que sea
y todo eso
las opiniones de otros si no tratamos de
comunicar esas cosas convertirán en
prensa docente compita la experiencia
listos del andador de historias de la
improvisación con todo este punto que me
gusta
original y no solamente compartir m
la página está súper bien resumen
después de toda esta aventura detenerme
me di cuenta que estaba escuchando y que
tenía que escuchar más
y tengo que tener la voluntad de cambiar
y no tenerle miedo al cambio me di
cuenta que tenía que aceptar que no ha
cambiado y ahora puedo seguir haciendo
las cosas como las hacía me di cuenta
que tenía que tomar decisiones
comprender lo que el que tengo te coloco
en este con la docencia tengo la
experiencia y televisión de bares en
teatro los contactos y bla bla bla
ok este nuevo proyecto
y ahora estoy aquí compartiendo les en
que está dividida en este momento
estoy dándole vueltas de tuerca a todo
este auto no solo para que no se desarme
sino porque siempre de cuando es cuando
hay que detenerse a realizar cómo está
ese auto que se llama vida
todos los días
momentos clave
no puede ser mecánico de láser
nuestra pensante por qué no
si hubiera hecho porque si podría en la
noche
no puedes dormir
de verdes cosas en tu vida
qué cosas
en el pasado para los tristes a veces
mismos mucho en el futuro y paramos a
nuestros
y nos perdemos de la posibilidad de
construir una vida maravillosa
que sea un aventón
yo les voy a decir estoy empezando a
lectura muy interesante
estoy muy contento de ser todo lo que
tengo para lo que el estado de redes
sociales
de una vuelta de tuerca la vida
tú eres el que sabe
y si no realiza sus cuatro puntos
otro regalo que todo el día de hoy
escuchar de verdad entiendas escucha en
la pregunta de cambiar
con esto valora los por algo está ahí no
tengo que utilizar
vale voy a apostar y con esto sumó y
asume riesgos lo que te cueste es eso lo
que te cueste es el 10
en esa habitación que nadie quiere
detrás de todos para que la
reglamentación
y vacío
pero hay otras personas que asumen los
riesgos y empiezan a fijar el carro y
entra en la habitación saben que hay
sentirse la persona
gracias
[Aplausos]